a film that kills you if you watch it i
thought i already watched geely well
it's american horror stories episode 3
and we're taking a deep drive
in to the latest episode the puns get
worse
after last week's double episode which
received fairly lukewarm reviews we
actually have an episode that's totally
original but
did it fall flat we're going to be
taking a look at the episode and of
course all those easter eggs and
connections to the ahs
universe so grab some popcorn unzip your
pants and make sure to like and
subscribe because
here we go starting in la where of
course horror stories this film there's
nothing quite like making out to bob
ross
this is actually a well-calculated plan
by chad who we see here making out with
his girlfriend kelly as he goes on to
tell his friends in the next scene he's
heard that
watching bob ross can stimulate certain
parts of the brain that
basically gives you the equivalent of a
brain orgasm so why not put that on in
the background when you're trying to get
lucky
this logic is later applied to the
horror movie rabbit rabbit where instead
of it inducing orgasms it turns you into
a murderous zombie but more on that in a
bit kelly isn't ready to give it up she
wants to take her time however her
friend dee says it's actually because
she's afraid of the dick
you're just scared of the dick it's
funny then that an alien poster hangs
above the couple as they make out as the
film is largely seen as an allegory for
fear of male penetration
seriously look it up after chad's
friends hear that kelly isn't putting
out they tell him the best way to get a
girl is through fear that's why taking a
girl to a horror movie is so successful
you tickle that fight or flight response
she's an oyster
ready for shocking there's this movie
called rabbit rabbit which originally
premiered in 1986
legend says the movie was so terrifying
that the audience went crazy and started
attacking each other
six people died at the premiere the same
thing happened at space jam chad of
course has to look into this finding a
video of a government hearing where
tipper gore chastises the director of
rabbit rabbit for inspiring violence
in real life tipper gore the wife of
former vice president al gore used her
power to create the parents music
resource center which was successful at
getting record labels to put warning
labels on music that contained
violent or sexually explicit lyrics if
you want to learn more about this i
highly recommend weird history's how
twisted sister outclass congress i'll
leave a link to that video in the
description below
the director of rabbit rabbit is
portrayed by none other than ahs
favorite john carroll lynch you may
recognize him as having played twisty
the clown in season 4's freak show as
well as seven's cult
john wayne gacy in season 5's hotel and
most recently as mr jingles in season
9's 1984. he outright attacks tipper
when she orders all the prints of his
movie be destroyed we also get a new
intro for the episode basically
confirming that each standalone episode
of horror stories will have its own
custom ahs introduction so chad has
kelly out to the drive-in
and she accepts but when they arrive
they're greeted by a woman named ruth
you may recognize the actress who plays
her as the same one who played pepper
in season 2's asylum and samantha crowe
in season 8's apocalypse she's
apparently a survivor from the original
1986 showing of rabbit rabbit telling
them that she lost her eye when her
boyfriend went crazy
and ate it out of her and here's a great
addition to ahs adrian barbeau
she's been in a ton of john carpenter
films like escape from new york and the
fog
and was once even married to him she
plays the crabby drive-in owner slash
projectionist and she's pissed the print
of the film is late
we'll later see the director himself
deliver it which is all part of his
master plan
some cool easter eggs here like the
mention of william castles the tingler
which was a 1959 film that actually used
a device
embedded in theater seats to zap
audience members during scary scenes
here we see the music of rabbit rabbit
was composed by none other than ed
sanchez the director of this episode
and it is true that rabbit rabbit is a
british superstition wherein you're
supposed to say
rabbit rabbit upon waking up on the
first day of the month to give you good
luck
ruth tries one last time to get them to
pull the plug in the movie but you know
no one ever listens to the crazy person
in a horror film kelly decides she's
gonna go all the way with chad so much
so that it steams up the car making it
impossible to view the film which is all
for the best since when the film does
start rolling it turns its watchers into
blood-thirsty zombies
hoping to avoid another massacre ruth
heads up to the projection room where
the projectionist has
already fully turned and it sucks to be
ruth who gets her other eye promptly
destroyed but not as bad as what happens
to milo's penis
pretty soon the entire drive-in is
filled with zombies kelly struggles to
maneuver the car to escape eventually
pinning her best friend
now turns zombie into the side of the
lobby let's all go to the lobby
so go to the lobby let's all go to the
lobby
to get ourselves a treat chad and kelly
make their way into the projection room
where they turn
off the film but the damage is already
done not to mention the zombie
projectionist who tries to kill him who
chad makes quick work of it's
really bloody and what projection room
wouldn't be complete without a shotgun
and ammo the two decide that instead of
going to the police where they would be
held and interrogated for hours
they're going to track down the director
before he can give another print to the
encore performance which is happening
later the next day but on their way out
chad finds his friend quinn has turned
into a zombie and has to cut him out of
his life so kelly and chad track down
larry bitterman the director to a
trailer out in the boonies however they
find it quite odd he owns a rolls-royce
more on that in a bit on the television
larry watches with glee as news reports
show attacks spreading into nearby
neighborhoods
this is cut short when he's confronted
by kelly and chat larry has made it his
life work creating a cinematic
experience
when he was a second cutter for william
friedkins the exorcist it was his idea
to splice in two frames of a demon's
face
a subliminal message which freaked out
viewers so much so that some pregnant
women even went into early labor this is
actually in the exorcist movie
if you pause the film after father
carys's dream sequence about his
deceased mother
you'll get this face this is actually
linda blair's stand-in
she's wearing the first version of
makeup artist dick smith's rendition for
possessed linda blair before the
director decided to go in a different
direction
since his time working on that film
larry became obsessed with the perfect
combination of image and sound that
would trigger the fear center of the
brain
spending his years in jail after
assaulting tipper gore
researching things like mk ultra mk
ultra being the secret cia
program where a variety of illegal tests
were performed on humans
it wasn't until he found his editor had
gone crazy cutting rabbit rabbit and i
mean
literally cutting that he knew he was on
to something but chad and kelly aren't
having it as punishment for his crimes
they shoot his legs and take the
original copy of the film
and burn it on the stove leaving larry
to burn and die in his trailer there are
a few quick nods to jason voorhees and
pennywise here as well but let's get
back to that rolls royce outside
as kelly and chad finally get to take
each other's v-cards we see a new film
has been added to netflix
yes a digital copy of rabbit rabbit has
come online
and i wouldn't be surprised if this
netflix and chill turns into a netflix
and kill
i guess we know where that rolls royce
money came from the episode ends on this
same shot from the beginning a view of
la but this time
it's complete pandemonium as people have
gone crazy after watching the film so
what did i think of the episode
i thought it was a slight step up from
last week's rubber woman and that's
partially because this felt like an
original story to me whereas last week
was a rehash of murder house that really
didn't offer anything new
at least this episode tried injecting
some freshness to it
and i hope they continue to try as this
show hits its stride if we can get a
couple gem episodes this season i'll
continue to watch
but enough about me what did you think
of episode 3
drive-in i want to hear your thoughts
and comments below thanks for watching
everyone remember to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
find me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much